soir à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france alors on l'a vu
marche aujourd'hui s'est déroulé dans le
calme avec de nombreux collectifs qui
ont rejoint cette marche avec vous
aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que vous retenez signalement
de cette journée je retiens que est
indifférent achète un gisti et à nos
souffrances d'un en fin de compte au
niveau de la population
on a vu que les gens se sentaient
concernés et et qu'il était là pour nous
soutenir et on compte bien sûr eu on a
bien besoin d'eux et et nous va écouter
on sait pas la manche on ne monte pas ce
qu'on demande c'est c'est tout à fait
légitime on demande à ce que les quatre
policiers qui sont directement impliqués
dans la mort de mon époux soient déjà
dans un premier temps suspendu de leurs
fonctions car il s'en indigne de rester
dans la police étant donné qu'ils ont
ils ont tué un père de pères de famille
ils ont des comptes à rendre comme
n'importe quel citoyen et il représente
pas du tout aujourd'hui la loi ou cette
corporation policière qui est censé
courir protéger et aider ils n'ont pas
leur place dans la police et on peut pas
on peut pas accepter qu'il soit toujours
en fonction c'est pas possible donc à
chaque fois qu'on aura l'opportunité de
de réclamer ce droitier de justice par
le fera sans cesse trois de ses
policiers mis en cause ont été mises en
examen à ce que selon vous c'est le
signe que l'on tête avance finalement à
wil enquête
rien à dire en face à ça mais le temps
que ça mes mails enquête lui avance il
ya des expertises loire autour d'
expertise qui sont assez régulièrement
on a pu grâce aux vidéos grâce aux deux
témoignages expertises
on a pu prouver que ces quatre policiers
étaient directement impliqués dans la
mort de cédric et maintenant ce qu'on
attend c'est une réponse du gouvernement
qui doit reconnaître
voilà qui lui qui a une grosse dérive
que c'est affligeant et goûts et pour
toutes les autres familles des victimes
et qu'on peut pas continuer comme ça
enfin aujourd'hui ils ont des comptes à
rendre et il faut faire en sorte que
tout ça on va pas assister mais les
familles sont pas systématiquement
déchets dans les rues pour réclamer
justice
on va faire en sorte plus d'injustice
qu'il soit commis et là je crois qu'on
commencera mi allen est ce que vous vous
êtes confiante parce que l'un de vos
avocats maître arié alimi a déclaré
aujourd'hui un chez nos confrères de
france info que systématiquement dans
les dossiers de violences policières il
ya une volonté de protéger les
fonctionnaires de police auteur des
faits ce que vous êtes d'accord avec les
as oui complètement s'est incliné alors
on l'a vu en acheter plus trop du juré
est systématiquement quand on se fait
autour de nous auprès des familles des
victimes
quand il ya un procès c'est
systématiquement un non lieu est encore
une fois même même une instruction par
un luth et on peut pas on peut pas
accepter on peut pas tolérer donc on
invite à un maximum de personnes à se
joindre
voilà à cette cause et à faire en sorte
que les policiers ne soient pas amenés à
tuer des des injustement gratuitement
des citoyens qui sont en fin de vie qui
demandent qu'à vivre en fait on se
souvient on se souvient qu'à l'époque le
ministre de l'intérieur en poste
christophe castaner vous avez reçu
il vous avait donné des garanties à
l'époque effectivement il nous avait
promis qu'une fois que red effet avéré
en ce sens après il y aurait forcément
une suspension des quatre policiers
cela n'a pas été fait et il avait
également
il avait également évoqué le fait qu'il
avait l'intention de mettre un terme à
la rrq et en le mans et hop la tâche
centrale de ce que je sais c'est
toujours mais enfin c'est cette pratique
est toujours d'actualité
on a entendu tout à l'heure et les
coquerelles faire le lien avec l affaire
georgia floyd c'était le cas aussi de
dassa traoré qui participait d'ailleurs
à cette marche qui avait aussi fait le
lien vous aussi vous le faites ce lien
vous vous ne craignez pas qu'on vous le
reproche parce que ça a été souvent le
cas dans dans le cas de la sphère adama
traoré
forcément on sait le lien tout à fait
logique et je vous offre pour une grosse
reprocherait en fait on n'est plus
aujourd'hui en mesure de reprocher pas
mal de choses et je vois pas ce qu'on va
nous reprocher à notre patience le
d'imiter notre appel à la paix qu'est ce
qu'on va nous reprocher exactement de
prendre notre mal en patience histoire
aujourd'hui le combat il va se
poursuivre dans la rue notamment aux
côtés de du collectif stop la sécurité
globale
ah oui oui ça c'est on est on est lié on
est lié on est tout coeur avec eux et on
pense que notre place est d'ailleurs la
place de tous les citoyens qui
souhaitent préserver leurs droits et
leurs libertés
on leur donne tous rendez vous aux
différentes manifestations qui va y
avoir successivement pour en janvier
pour s'opposer à toutes ces lois
liberticides et et à ce futur est un
police qui risquent d'émerger
tôt ou tard en fait et qui est déjà là
même j'ai envie de vous dire mais vous
savez aussi que ces manifestations
contre la loi sécurité globale en marche
ses manifestations il ya aussi
des heurts avec les forces de police
par rapport à cela quel est votre
sentiment c'est récurrent
moi personnellement avec mes enfants on
a participé à la manifestation
on s'est retrouvé presque presque
asphyxié en fin de compte
et alors qu'on n'avait rien fait de mal
on est et on était là un marché comme
tout le monde et je ne sais pas pourquoi
subitement on a été chargée de bombes
lacrymogènes et va je crois que c'est
bonne idée de ne plus venir manifester
ou faut tenir le coup et essayer de
faire les deux choses
pacifiquement possible et par rapport à
ça par rapport à ces manifestations qui
étaient dégénère à qui vous en voulez le
plus peut-être pas aux forces de l'ordre
qui exécute aussi des ordres oui mais
après ça reste des crs des citoyens
avant tout et là ils ont ce qu'on
appelle le libre arbitre et enfin je
veux dire si demain on leur demande de
ballet de balancer les manifestants dans
la scène est pour l'heure dix derrière
et que l'impunité
ces deux morts le mot du jour est ce
qu'ils vont nous balancer aussi dans la
seine on va pas en arriver là sachant
que ça a bien eu lieu mais là avant nous
on est là pour dire stop non et on a
beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'on estime que
dans ces moments là c'est des moments de
réflexion de remise en question et c'est
de là qu'ils émergent injustement des
réformes des nouvelles idées pour
essayer d'améliorer les choses là
aujourd'hui
enfin je viens le but c'est pas sans
cesse de réclamer la justice c'est de
faire en sorte que ces gens justice
n'ait pas lieu
faut prendre le problème à l'envers
parce que c'est faux il faut prendre le
problème à sa racine est la racine c'est
que c'est qu'aujourd'hui les ceux qui
dirigent la police les donneurs d'un cd
gens malveillants malin malin
fonctionner nuit tzadik et on peut pas
les wc donné des gens comme ça je vois
qu'ils mettent en péril la vie de
citoyens qui viennent légitimement
contester une loi ou une réforme ou je
ne sais pas encore merci beaucoup à vous
doria souvient
vous êtes donc la veuve de cédric joue
via merci pour avoir réagi sur rtl
france à l'issue de cette marche
commémorative en hommage à votre mari